bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
et sur public sénat ce matin je vous
propose de voir la lecture du discours
de politique générale hier à 15 heures
pendant que manuel valls était à
l'assemblée nationale pour prononcer ce
discours devant les députés qu'il leur
demandait la confiance et leur présenter
le programme la feuille de route du
gouvernement balle ce2 au sénat et bien
c'est fait laurent fabius le suivant
donc dans l'ordre protocolaire qui
prononçait mot pour mot le même discours
alors les enjeux n'étaient pas tout à
fait les mêmes puisque à l'assemblée
nationale le premier ministre a demandé
et la confiance le député confiance qui
lui a été accordée puisqu'il a obtenu 2
169 voix pour mais il faut tout de même
noter qu'il ya eu 32 députés socialistes
abstentionnistes 32 députés frondeurs au
sénat en revanche est bien il n'y avait
pas de vote de confiance pas de débat à
la suite de ce legs de cette lecture du
discours de politique générale en
revanche on a pu noter que le dise que
l'hémicycle était tout de même assez
comble et cela malgré le fait que les
sénateurs soit en campagne
en effet ils sont pour la plupart en
circonscription à l'occasion du
renouvellement du sénat le 28 septembre
prochain renouvellement de la moitié de
la haute assemblée tout de suite donc
retour à cette lecture cet étui hier
dans l'hémicycle à 15 heures
monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
il est rare sous la vème république
à cinq mois d'un précédent vote de
solliciter à nouveau la confiance du
parlement
c'est pourtant ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui en nous présentant devant
avec le président de la république nous
avons fait ce choix exigeant dès la
constitution du nouveau gouvernement car
la clarification apportée au sein de
l'exécutif
devait trouver sa traduction ici même
par respect à votre égard par respect
pour le peuple français par respect de
l'éthique de responsabilité qui nous a
dit
dans ce moment de vérité pour la france
le premier ministre à travers la lecture
que je vais faire de son discours avec
son équipe gouvernementale
vient rechercher votre conscience pour
poursuivre son action et cela compte
tenu de l'évolution exceptionnelle de la
conjoncture économique européenne elle
se caractérise par une croissance faible
et un risque de déflation inquiétant qui
remettent pas en cause les prévisions
les plus raisonnables j'y reviendrai
voilà l'exigence que nous nous sommes
fixés la clarté la cohérence la vérité
vis-à-vis du parlement et donc des
français voilà pourquoi le vote de
confiance d'aujourd'hui n'est pas un vol
banal
c'est un vote déterminant qui engage
chacun notre
la gauche gouverne depuis le 6 mai 2012
depuis que les français par leurs
suffrages ont porté à la tête de l'état
monsieur françois hollande est lui en
donner une majorité notre majorité
oui nous gouvernons c'est un honneur
c'est une responsabilité immense
et l'importance du moment nous oblige
tous ici à nous hisser à la hauteur des
événements
le contexte international est rempli de
menaces
crise en ukraine les tensions avec la
russie
ramène l'europe aux heures de la guerre
froide cet été la guerre à gaza à
repousser encore plus loin les
perspectives de paix entre israéliens et
palestiniens
en afrique de l'ouest
les ravages des mollahs et rentes des
états déjà fragile et la méditerranée
est toujours un cimetière pour des
milliers de migrants
le monde et d'abord confronté à une
menace terroriste
dont l'ampleur et l'évolution saute
inédite aujourd'hui même en syrie et en
irak
les groupuscules éclaté d'hier sont en
passe
s'accaparer des états et de l'ensemble
des moyens qui vont avec dans le seul
but de démultiplier la capacité d'action
et leur logique de terreur au moment où
je vous parle
930 française ou résidant sur notre
territoire sont impliqués dans le
terrorisme en irak et en syrie il
représente une menace majeure pour la
france
la france le chef de l'état sa
diplomatie s'est armé et mobiliser
pleinement pour répondre à ce défi de
sécurité certainement le plus grand de
ce début du 21ème siècle
la france assume totalement ses
responsabilités celles que l'histoire
lui a donné celle d'un membre permanent
du conseil de sécurité
elles portent assistance aux chrétiens
d'orient et aux minorités victimes de la
terreur elle travaille à une riposte
globale sur le plan intérieur comme sur
le plan extérieur c'est l'enjeu du plan
de lutte contre les filières jihadistes
qui va vous est présentée c'est aussi
l'un des enjeux de la conférence sur
l'irak organisé hier même à paris et
dans ces moments face à ces menaces
l'unité nationale s'impose je ne doute
pas qu'elle sera au rendez vous
il ya aussi la crise économique cette
crise qui frappe et l'europe et la
france depuis maintenant
elle brise toutes les certitudes elle
alimente tous les malaises malaise
social malaise démocratique malaise
identitaire
la crise économique ne se résume
évidemment pas que des chiffres car des
indicateurs elle tourmente les villes et
quotidien les repères les familles les
quartiers populaires les territoires
ruraux et tous les liens qui nous
unissent
et je comprends les impatiences les
doutes les colères ils sont légitimes
quand le chômage atteint des niveaux
aussi élevés et depuis si longtemps
mais face à cela quelle attitude faut-il
adopter la fébrilité les virages de zig
zag le renoncement non
gouverner c'est résister
gouverner c'est tenir gouverné ces
réformes est
gouvernée c'est dire la vérité gouverner
c'est aller chercher la confiance
surtout quand c'est difficile
le gouvernement sollicite votre
confiance afin de poursuivre sa
politique économique
le premier ministre lee site votre
confiance car la politique du
gouvernement est guidé par les valeurs
de la république des valeurs chères la
gauche la nation le principe d'égalité
de justice qui s'adresse à tous les
français
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
gouverner c'est d'abord mener une
politique économique calibré et adapté à
la réalité du pays sur ces bancs
personne ne l'ignorent la france et la
zone euro font face à une situation
exceptionnelle la croissance ne
redémarre pas et s'ajoute à cela une
quasi absence d'inflation
personne n'avait anticipé pour 2014 en
ce qui le concerne l'inflation très
faible 0 5%
une croissance tout aussi faible 0 4%
conduiront à des recettes publiques
moins élevées qu'attendu
cet été nous avons fait un choix clair
ni hausse d'impôt ni économies
budgétaires supplémentaires
c'est un choix politique c'est un choix
économique
car nous ne voulons pas entrer dans une
spirale dépressive c'est un choix social
parce que les efforts demandés sont déjà
considérables nous adaptons donc le
rythme de réduction des déficits à cette
situation par conséquent le déficit des
administrations publiques devrait se
situer à 4 4% du produit intérieur brut
cette année nous avons comme objectif de
le ramener à 4,3 en 2015
mais rien ne doit nous faire dévier de
notre engagement
à réaliser 50 milliards d'économies en
trois ans dont 21 milliards en 2015 il
faut maîtriser l'évolution des dépenses
publiques leurs niveaux trop élevés a
nourri depuis des années l'augmentation
des déficits et de la dette et nous le
savons tous il y a des marges pour
vendre la dépense plus efficace
réduire la dépense plutôt qu'augmenter
encore les impôts nous baissons la
pression fiscale car les impôts dans
leur calme ulation depuis 2010 ont
atteint un niveau insupportable pour les
français
un premier pas a été accompli en
direction de plus de 4 millions de
ménages cette rentrée nous poursuivrons
ce mouvement en 2015 6 millions de
ménages seront concernées par la baisse
de l'impôt soit venu ce choix tirent
aussi les conséquences de la décision du
conseil constitutionnel sur les charges
salariales
le rythme de réduction du déficit doit
être aussi adapté en europe ceci suppose
utiliser toutes les flexibilités du
pacte de stabilité et de croissance
soutenir la croissance en europe
nécessite également une politique
monétaire adaptée il y a cinq mois à
cette même tribune nous dénoncions les
conséquences d'un euro trop cher les
réactions ont été très vifs mais nous
constatons aujourd'hui que cette idée a
fait son chemin
les choses bougent et je pense que nous
avons contribué à les faire bouger les
décisions de la banque centrale
européenne ont permis d'annoncer une
baisse de 10 centimes de l'euro par
rapport au dollar
appliqué à toutes nos entreprises
exportatrices cette baisse représente
des dizaines de milliers d'emplois
préservés il faut aller plus loin encore
parce qu'il ya urgence la zone euro est
en train de décrocher par rapport au
reste du monde le président de la bce
lui mais monsieur mario draghi a déclaré
qu'il était prêt à d'autres types
d'intervention pour soutenir la
croissance il a aussi recommandé que les
politiques nationales structurelles soit
accompagnée au niveau européen par une
politique globale de la demande ses
positions
ce sont celles que l'associé de porter
le président de la république depuis
2012 le fmi l'oscd eu de nombreux
économistes les syndicats européens le
dise finalement pas autre chose c'est
par l'investissement que l'europe
retrouvera une fois sens solide et
durera monsieur jean claude juncker
annoncé un plan de 300 milliards d'euros
pour l'investissement en trois ans mais
annoncée est une chose concrétiser est
une autre chose
nous travaillons donc
nous travaillons donc pour obtenir une
action puissante en matière
d'infrastructures de grands projets de
numérique ou encore de formation des
jeunes
cette action pourrait ainsi l'europe est
vitale car nous le voyons bien le projet
européen est menacé de toutes parts dans
tous les pays par la défiance dans les
populistes par rejeter cette grande
aventure qui a une idée peuple et qui a
garanti la paix l'engagement de l'europe
de répondre à la tente des peuples cela
impose un dialogue sincère et exigeant
entre la france et l'allemagne nous
demandons pas de faciliter la france
décide elle seule de ce qu'elle doit
faire
les l'accord entre nos deux pays est
indispensable pour relancer la
croissance et redonner au projet
européen son ambition véritable
l'allemagne est une grande nation que
nous respectons le premier ministre
rencontrera la chancelière merkel la
semaine prochaine notre message doit
être entendu
l'allemagne doit assumer ses
responsabilités notre responsabilité
commune est donc historique
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
principale faiblesse de notre économie
c'est la perte de compétitivité de nos
entreprises
comme l'a relevé le rapport gallois dès
novembre 2012 un véritable décrochage
est intervenu il y a dix années pertes
de parts de marché à l'export
dégradation continue des marges de nos
entreprises industrielles ainsi il n'y a
pas eu de créations d'emploi nettes dans
l'industrie depuis
c'est pourquoi par vos votes vous avez
engagée dès décembre 2012 le crédit
d'impôt pour la compétitivité l'emploi
et puis il ya quelques semaines le pacte
de responsabilité et de solidarité a
annoncé par le président de la
république ces dispositifs commencent à
produire leurs effets au 1er janvier
prochain
le coût du travail baissera d'environ 10
points de cotisations pour de nombreuses
entreprises et il n'y aura plus aucune
cotisation de sécurité sociale au niveau
du smic mais soyons lucides ces mesures
nécessiteront du temps pour porter
pleinement leurs fruits nous devons être
aux côtés de toutes nos entreprises de
nos entrepreneurs nos pme/pmi nous
artisans aux commerçants car ce sont les
entreprises qui créent des richesses de
l'emploi et dans une concurrence
mondiale
merci de vos applaudissements car enfin
ce sont les entreprises qui créent les
richesses et l'emploi et dans une
concurrence mondiale qui ne fait aucun
cadeau pourquoi serions nous le seul
grand pays à ne pas aider nos
entreprises pour qu'elles innovent
qu'elles partent à la conquête de
nouveaux marchés
merci à nouveau de vos applaudissements
les entreprises
ce ne sont pas que des actionnaires
ce sont aussi des ouvriers des salariés
des cadres
des ingénieurs qui travaillent ensemble
et des nos entreprises ce n'est pas un
choix idéologique c'est un choix
stratégique et le premier ministre n'a
jamais cessé de dire ceci quel que soit
le lieu où il s'est exprimé la nation
consent un effort sans précédent de 40
milliards d'euros sur trois ans mais cet
effort exige que chacun soit à la
hauteur de ses responsabilités
le pacte ce n'est pas un moyen
d'augmenter les dividendes ou les plus
hautes rémunérations
le pacte
le pacte est là pour créer un climat de
confiance et pour redonner des marges de
manoeuvre aux entreprises elles en ont
besoin et il doit se traduire en termes
d'investissements dans boues rouges de
formation ou d'accueil de jeunes en
apprentissage
les partenaires sociaux
ont décidé d'en discuter au niveau de
chaque branche
aujourd'hui la majorité des branches
professionnelles à engager ou va engager
les négociations
mais pour 17 grandes branches les
discussions n'ont pas encore démarré il
faut donc que les choses avancent et la
confiance doit être réciproque
personnes et nous le disons clairement
patronat ne doit prendre le risque
d'affaiblir par je ne sais quelle
provocation par je ne sais quelle
surenchère le dialogue social
indispensable qui est la marque de ce
quinquennat dans ce domaine comme dans
bien d'autres il faut savoir faire
preuve de constantes et savoir respecter
les règles du jeu le premier ministre
présidera dans quelques semaines le
nouveau comité de suivi des aides
publiques il associera partenaires
sociaux et parlementaires et nous
souhaitons alors que nous fassions
ensemble constat qu'aucune des grandes
proches professionnels ne manque à
l'appel pour nos jeunes et pour l'emploi
la représentation nationale est
particulièrement engagée et vigilante
sur ce point de travers
notamment à travers la mission sur le
séïsme redresser notre économie passe
aussi par un soutien direct à notre
industrie nous nous croyons à la main
visible de l'état notre état a son rôle
à jouer dans une économie de marché et
c'est ce qu'il a fait par exemple dans
le cas d'alstom l'état agit en aidant à
l'émergence de leaders français
compétitif au niveau mondial dans les
secteurs stratégiques dans les domaines
des tgv du futur de textiles
intelligents de la chimie verte de ce
qu'on appelle le big data la france a
des cartes en main c'est vrai pour la
transition énergétique qui est une
avancée majeure et impérieuse pour la
préservation de notre environnement mais
aussi un formidable relais de croissance
pour des emplois durables et non
délocalisables et fait l'objet d'un
projet de loi que vous allez bientôt
examiner l'avenir c'est bien sûr le
numérique pour lequel sourd une grande
concertation elle aussi préalable un
travail législatif enfin l'état doit
agir en orientant les pannes des
français vers l'économie réelle et en
favorisant le financement de
l'innovation le crédit impôt recherche
le programme d'investissements d'avenir
la banque publique d'investissement ont
fait leurs preuves
l'investissement c'est la clé de la
reprise un pays qui investit moins vous
qui n'investit plus ne pourra pas
trouver sa place dans la mondialisation
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
redresser notre économie c'est aider nos
entreprises notre industrie nos
agricultures notre recherche notre
diversité nos scientifiques c'est
favoriser aussi l'économie sociale et
solidaire elle représente un gisement
formidable d'emplois c'est également
mener les réformes nécessaires elle
commence bien entendu ces réformes par
les administrations publiques
nous avons lancé un exercice de revue
des missions de l'état qui associera les
usages et les collectivités locales
particuliers entreprises sans oublier
bien sûr les fonctionnaires eux-mêmes
nous réformons l'état nous réformant les
entreprises publiques comme nous venons
le faire avec succès pour la réforme
ferroviaire
nous voulons réformer aussi les
collectivités territoriales vous avez
déjà voté le passage de 22 à 13 régions
la représentation nationale
ceux qui hier semble être un faisable à
certains est donc en passe d'être
accompli aujourd'hui ces nouvelles
régions plus grande plus forts sont
nécessaires pour répondre aux défis de
l'aménagement et du développement du
territoire des intercommunalités seront
renforcés car elles sont à même de mener
les politiques publiques de proximité
qu'attendent les français
quant au département vous le savez le
pragmatisme nous guide vers trois
solutions dans les départements dotés
d'une métropole à l'exemple de lyon la
fusion des deux structures pour être
retenu lorsque le département compte des
intercommunalités forte là les
compétences départementales
pour être assumée par une fédération
d'intercommunalité enfin dans les
départements notamment ruraux où les
communautés de communes n'atteignent pas
la masse critique
le conseil départemental sera maintenu
avec des compétences clarifie
nous ne doutons pas que le parlement
apportera toute son expertise dans ce
débat les assises des ruralités que nous
venons lancé y contribueront également
dès lors la concomitance des élections
départementales et régionales n'est plus
une obligation
précisons le calendrier les élections
départementales sont maintenus en mars
2015 conformément à la loi votée en 2013
les élections régionales avec la
nouvelle carte auront bien lieu saint
réformer c'est aussi libérer toutes les
énergies créatives de ce pays et
simplifier les normes le projet de loi
croissance
permettra de simplifier les formalités
les procédures et la vie quotidienne des
français
ce n'est pas une loi qui stigmatisent
n'est pas contre les professions
réglementées elle agit pour leur fournir
les outils juridiques pour se moderniser
elle stimulera l'investissement en
rendant plus lisible et plus stable
l'environnement législatif et
réglementaire
elle contribuera également à
l'attractivité de la france dans le
monde
avec l'ouverture des magasins le
dimanche et en soirée dans les zones
touristiques en nous appuyant notamment
sur le rapport bailly
concernant la politique de l'emploi il
est possible de donner de la souplesse
et de la visibilité aux entreprises tout
en améliorant les droits et réelle des
salariés nous l'avons montré au cours
des deux dernières années avec plusieurs
lois issues d'un accord entre
partenaires sociaux une nouvelle
négociation vous le savez bien d'être
lancé sur ce qu'on appelle les seuils il
y aller d'ici la fin de cette année un
chemin a trouvé qui permette d'avoir un
véritable dialogue social dans
l'entreprise en fonction de sa taille
sans entraver leur croissance
progrès économique et progrès social
sont intimement liés
une politique
de l'emploi plus efficace c'est aussi un
soutien plus fort et un suivi plus
personnalisé
exigeant même pour les demandeurs
d'emploi qui cependant ne doivent pas
être stigmatisé personne n'aspire
évidemment à devenir chômeur ni à le
rester une nouvelle convention
tripartite état unedic pôle emploi peut
être signé d'ici la fin de l'année elle
devra améliorer l'action de pôle emploi
pour mieux connaître les besoins des
entreprises et utiliser toutes les
potentialités du numérique nous devons
aussi impérativement encourager
l'apprentissage qui depuis quelques
années recul la mobilisation des
entreprises est essentiel
même lorsqu il y à moins d'an gauche du
fait de la crise il faut former
davantage nous nous retrouvons à la fin
de la semaine avec les partenaires
sociaux et les régions pour cette
relance de l'apprentissage
et si certains blocages freinait la
réussite de notre politique
d'apprentissage alors nous lèverons oui
nous réformons et nous allons continuer
à le faire mais réformer ce n'est pas
cassé et ce n'est pas régresser et comme
le premier ministre l'a déjà dit il n'y
aura pas de remise en cause des 35
heures ni la durée légale du travail
réformée ce n'est pas réduire le smic
réforme est ce n'est pas supprimé le cdi
réformer ce n'est pas diminuer les
salaires dans la fonction publique
réforme et ce n'est pas cassé notre
modèle social
réformer
c'est affirmer des priorités en refusant
l'austérité quand nous créons 60000
postes dans l'éducation nationale près
de 5000 dans la justice la police et la
gendarmerie
nous ne faisons pas de l'austérité quand
nous préservons le budget de la culture
pour la création et les spectacles
vivants nous ne faisons pas de
l'austérité quand nous augmentons le rsa
de 10% et que nous lançons un grand plan
de lutte contre la pauvreté nous ne
faisons pas de l'austérité quand nous
créons les emplois d'avenir et une
garantie jeunes pour aider a débuté dans
la vie nous ne faisons pas de
l'austérité quand nous augmentons
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire et les
bourses pour les étudiants nous ne
faisons pas de l'austérité quand nous
permettant à 150000 personnes depuis
2012 de partir à la retraite dès 60 ans
nous ne faisons pas de l'austérité
et quand je vous l'annoncé aujourd'hui
nous valorisons le minimum vieillesse à
800 euros
et quand de plus nous verserons
retraités qui perçoivent moins de 12 100
euros par mois une prime exceptionnelle
malgré la faible inflation nous ne
faisons pas de l'austérité
nous protégeons les plus fragiles les
plus modestes et nous défendons notre
modèle de société
quand nous investissons pour réaliser de
grandes infrastructures de transport ne
faisons pas de l'austérité nous
préparons l'avenir pour cela il faut des
moyens financiers et les contrats de
projets etat-régions 2015 2020 seront
signés d'ici à la fin de l'année
engageant 1,8 milliard d'euros de
financements de l'état et nous devons
tout faire pour préserver la capacité
d'investissement des collectivités
territoriales au fond la seule question
qui doit nous occuper c'est mener les
réformes indispensables avec courage
mais sans remettre en cause tout notre
modèle social ce modèle auquel nous
sommes attachés auquel les français sont
attachés qui fait même partie de notre
identité
l'héritage de deux siècles de conquêtes
sociales
ce modèle il faut l'adapter le
réinventer mais il n'a pas vécu il n'est
pas dépassé il est au coeur de notre
pacte républicain
ce débat doit s'ouvrir pleinement devant
les français y compris le cas échéant
avec un ancien président de la
république quelle france voulons nous
quelle france voulons nous pour nos
enfants quel modèle de société des fonds
nous défendons nous alors nous entendons
diverses propositions alternatives de
l'opposition notamment celle réclamant
100 ou même 150 milliards de coupes
budgétaires tout est possible mais il
faut dire alors la vérité aux français
et leur expliquer à quel prix et pour
quels sacrifices
combien de suppressions de postes dans
l'éducation nationale
les hôpitaux
combien de suppressions de postes dans
la police dans la gendarmerie et dans
nos armées ces choix voulez proposer ces
choix nous les refusons il faudra
assumer ce débat projet contre projet
chiffrage contre chiffrage voilà une
vraie confrontation démocratique est
utile pour les français
et
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
gouverner c'est affronter les
difficultés gouverner c'est agir
gouverner si répondre et regarder la
france telle qu'elle est gouvernée c'est
unir autour des valeurs de la république
ce que nous ressentons profondément dans
le climat actuel
que j'ai décrit plus haut c'est que nous
devons essayer de rassembler autour des
valeurs que nous partageons et qui
dépassent les différents clivages je le
dis avec gravité
réclamaient la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale
appelé à la démission du chef de l'état
c'est tout simplement mettre en cause
nos institutions et donc vouloir
affaiblir la france oui il y à une crise
des valeurs il ya une impression que les
règles qui fondent notre pacte
républicain ne sont pas respectées
la société est dure souvent violente
elle est marquée par la montée des
incivilités par des défis permanents
lancé à toutes les figures de l'autorité
les enseignants les juges les parents
dans un autre domaine les forces de
l'ordre il y a aussi cette remise en
cause de la laïcité et cette montée
préoccupante des communautarismes le
racisme l'antisémitisme la tolérance les
actes anti musulmans anti chrétiens
l'homophobie
malheureusement gagne du terrain et
lorsque le valeur vacille c'est la
république qui recule nous sentons bien
également que notre pays se fragmente
entre gagnants et perdants de la
mondialisation
dans les périphéries les villes moyennes
les petites villes les espaces ruraux la
vie de tous les jours bien souvent ceux
des grappes les usines se délocalise des
exploitations agricoles disparaissent
des emplois sont détruits
des familles sont obligées d'aller vite
toujours plus loin des centres villes
les trajets en voiture coûte cher il
s'allonge les opportunités
professionnelles sont réduites alors que
la pauvreté la précarité
beaucoup de cases s'étendent il ya aussi
des quartiers devenus des ghettos
urbains ou l'échec de l'urbanisme dit
que bien souvent l'échec social est très
souvent les trafics les petits caïds
dans d'y imposer leur loi en faisant
régner la peur là encore c'est la
république qui recule il y à des
citoyens qui se sentent abandonnés
alors de plus en plus nombreux ils se
replient sur eux-mêmes ce désintérêt du
débat public car ils n'y croient plus et
si certains font le choix du repli c'est
aussi parce que la république n'a pas su
tenir ses promesses c'est parce que
trente ans de politique d'intégration en
faisant le choix de se diriger vers des
populations en fonction de leur origine
on fait fausse route
c'est abandonner de la république tous
essayent comme ils le peuvent de trouver
la protection que nous ne savons bien
souvent plus haut leur offrir eh bien
nous nous croyons que c'est là que se
trouve notre principal combat le combat
qui doit tous nous anime et nous
mobiliser parce que nous aimons la
france et que nous voulons le meilleur
pour elle nous devons retrouver nos
valeurs et notamment la plus essentielle
de toute légalité
retrouvez les valeurs de la république
ses rangs concrètes pour chaque citoyen
peu importe ses origines sa couleur de
peau son sexe retrouvez la promesse
républicaine peut importe aussi qu'ils
aient ou non une religion la laïcité
savons tous c'est le droit de croire ou
ne pas croire et c'était bien si
précieux dans notre république alors
arrêtons de stigmatiser les populations
en les ramenant constamment à leur
origine ou à leur religion nous ne
pouvons plus tolérer ces propos ces
actes
contre tous et notamment contre l'islam
bien sûr l'islam doit s'organiser dans
le cadre des valeurs républicaines mais
les musulmans de france sont des
citoyens à part entière et la république
doit protéger l'ensemble de ses citoyens
c'est cela une politique de citoyenneté
qui mobilise bien sûr nos politiques de
droit commun à l'école la santé la
nouvelle géographie de la politique de
la ville les investissements pour la
rénovation urbaine
mais qui respecte d'abord et fait preuve
de considération à l'endroit de tous que
l'on soit français depuis peu ou depuis
des générations
l'immigration c'est une opportunité une
chance un dynamisme pour d'autres pays
mais pour réussir elle peut être
organisé et régulé nous le devons à tous
ces nouveaux arrivants et nous le devons
à la france pour se construire une
nation a besoin de symboles qui
s'appelle notre drapeau et notre hymne
national
elle a besoin d'ordre est de règle cas
quand il n'y a ni or ni règle
ce sont toujours les plus faibles qui
souffrent en premier chaque citoyen de
la république a les mêmes droits et les
mêmes devoirs et c'est à nos policiers
et nos gendarmes à nos juges de
travailler ensemble pour les garantir et
pour les faire respecter une politique
de citoyenneté c'est aussi une politique
qui réaffirme la valeur du travail de
l'effort du mérite qui reconnaît la
créativité innovation qui défend ce qui
se donne du mal ce aussi pour qui le
travail peut créer des crises ou france
ceux enfin qui aimerais tu prends
travailler à nouveau
enfin renouer avec les valeurs de la
république c'est reprend le combat pour
l'égalité et doit s'appuyer ce combat
sur nos administrations sur l'état
qui est l'incarnation de notre modèle
social
nous entendons ce qui sans cesse demande
moins d'état mais nous savons que rien
n'est possible sans le service public
sans l'état sans le fonctionnaire
engagés chaque jour avec dévouement et
compétence au service des citoyens
qu'ils soient enfants personnes âgées
habitant de quartier donc non pas moins
d'état mais toujours mieux d'état un
état qui n'est pas que redistribution
par la fiscalité mais qui s'est
accompagnée et investir dans chaque
citoyen et nous pensons à nos outre-mer
qui font face à une situation difficile
marqué par la vie chère le chômage et
les problèmes de logement ils peuvent
compter sur ce gouvernement pour leur
développement économique et social
la république a toujours été le
patrimoine de ceux qui n'ont rien de
ceux à qui la vie n'a rien donné aux qui
ont tout perdu et la mission du
gouvernement sera de remettre pleinement
la république au service de tous pour
précisément casser ces inégalités
d'abord en agissant avec détermination
pour l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes c'est le principe même de notre
société
garantir les droits de tous les français
lutter avec acharnement pour que les
enfants aient les mêmes chances de
réussir dans la vie peu importe le
quartier ou de village où il habite
l'école de la république c'est bien
notre priorité
nous en augmentant les moyens avec les
créations de postes
la relance de l'éducation prioritaire la
priorité aux primaires la réforme des
métiers de l'éducation la formation des
maîtres mais nous savons qu augmenter
les moyens ne suffit pas et nous devons
avoir une réflexion bien sûr sur la
pédagogie nous ne pouvons pas accepter
de voir se multiplier ce qu'on appelle
les décrocheurs ces jeunes qui quittent
le système scolaire sans avoir obtenu de
diplôme tout comme ne l'acceptons pas
que 15 % 15 % des élèves présentent des
difficultés sévères en écriture et en
lecture et en mathématiques
à l'issue du primaire parce que le
savons que l'école c'est là où ça prenne
les valeurs de la république selon une
enquête un lieux d'apaisement avec pour
seul but l'intérêt de nos enfants et
nous croyons que sur ce point nous
pouvons et devons nous retrouver le
grand dessein de la république c'est
l'égalité des possibles et l'égalité des
possibles c'est de pouvoir débuter dans
la vie d'avoir une deuxième chance
lorsque c'est nécessaire on pourra venir
contrat de génération apprentissage
droit à la formation professionnelle
pour tous autant de mesures prises
renouer avec l'égalité républicaine
c'est faire en sorte que plus aucun de
nos concitoyens parce que c'est trop
cher ou parce que c'est trop loin né du
mal à se soigner vont garantir l'accès à
des soins de qualité
permettre à chacun de vieillir dans la
dignité nous le devons à nos personnes
âgées à ceux qui souffrent d'un handicap
et pour les familles modestes la
généralisation du tiers payant prévue
dans le projet de loi santé est une
avancée tout à fait décisive
rendre accessible aussi la justice du
quotidien la faillite faciliter l'accès
et voilà le sens de la réforme en cours
parce qu'un divorce une querelle entre
bailleur et propriétaire un conflit avec
son employeur cela dure toujours trop
longtemps et cela fragilise toujours les
plus modestes
renouer avec l'égalité républicaine
c'est aussi faciliter
l'accès au logement c'est pour ça que
nous avons annoncé un plan de relance
construire plus priorités sociales pour
les familles et c'est important on
regarde du dynamisme de notre
démographie mais c'est aussi un
impératif économique
sur l'encadrement des loyers il faut là
aussi être pragmatique évitons les faux
débats à paris et en petite couronne à
lille si les choses peuvent avancer tant
mieux qui compte aujourd'hui c'est que
l'on construise que la confiance
revienne dans ce secteur comme dans bien
d'autres ce qui compte c'est
l'efficacité et non pas l'idéologie
remettent la république au service de
tous c'est aussi un accès pour chacun la
création à l'émotion à la culture une
culture qui soit exigeante et populaire
un moteur économique pour notre pays
pour notre rayonnement grâce à notre
langue la francophonie pour son
attractivité mais ses soucis et surtout
l'ouverture aux autres la construction
l'individu et son émancipation
notre devoir notre responsabilité à tous
c'est pour mac chaque français que la
république ne l'a pas abandonné que le
projet des populistes et qu'une impasse
notre devoir c'est cessé de promettre
des jours meilleurs et enfin de les
construire
et nous savons que nous pouvons y
arriver que nous allons y arriver si
nous donnons le meilleur de nous mêmes
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
le premier ministre est à son poste
depuis maintenant cinq mois et croyez
qu'ils mesurent chaque jour l'ampleur de
la tâche qui lui a été confiée par le
président de la république
aujourd'hui il sait qu'en s'adressant à
vous par mon intermédiaire il s'adresse
à l'ensemble des français
nous savons que très souvent
les français ne croient plus et se
disent à quoi bon ce spectacle de la
politique politicienne nous afflige nous
savons aussi que pour vous élus de la
république le climat des dernières
semaines fait de narcissisme d'indignité
d'irresponsabilité rend la tâche encore
plus l'eau la force d'un engagement
politique la force de l'engagement d'une
vie
l'exemplarité qui l'imposent nous savons
ce que cela représente et nous savons ce
que cela représente pour vous cette
passion
que nous avons la france et de passion
l'engagement cette passion de servir
c'est ce qui nous fait tenir et face à
la responsabilité qui a été confiée au
premier ministre le premier ministre
sait quelle est sa mission sa seule
mission c'est d'avancer d'avancé contre
vents et marées guidés par une
bienveillance infini pour les français
guidée par sa passion de la france et
par le sens de l'état avancé et
gouverner n'en doutez pas un seul
instant dans la durée notre mission
notre responsabilité c'est de ne pas
laisser nos concitoyens tourner le dos à
la république de considérer chacun et de
faire confiance pour redonner confiance
c'est permettent partout en métropole
dans les outre-mer ou à l'étranger à
chaque français à chaque enfant à chaque
étudiant à chaque salarié à chaque
retraité de bénéficier aussi
concrètement que possible du progrès
notre pays est riche de tous ses talents
de sa jeunesse mais aussi de tous ces
bénévoles engagés dans les associations
qui font la force de tissu social c'est
aussi cela la générosité des français
alors nous vous invitons à défier les
pronostics les fatalités les idées
reçues qui à l'étranger ou même dans cet
hémicycle voudrait que notre pays ne
soit pas capable de se réformer et se
redresser la france n'est nullement
condamné à être la nation la plus
pessimiste pour peu que nous tendions le
cou à cette mauvaise mélodies
déclinistes questionner débattre porter
la contradiction tout cela est légitime
le dialogue c'est la démocratie et nous
nous voulons dire à la majorité que ce
qui nous unit est bien plus fort que ce
qui nous distingue c'est une gauche
moderne qui a le courage de gouverner le
courage de réformer soyons en fiers et
nous voulons dire aussi à l'opposition
que nous considérons l'écoutent et le
respect comme des principes fondamentaux
pour l'accomplissement de notre mission
et soyons fiers de cette mission que
nous toutes et nous tous avons reçu des
français
soyons fiers mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de
la mission que toutes et tous nous avons
reçu selon fier de les représenter et de
travailler pour eux soyons fiers de ce
que malgré les difficultés nous faisons
soyons fiers de relever de grands défis
soyons fiers de redresser notre pays oui
le premier ministre a besoin de votre
confiance hier aujourd'hui encore
toujours car cette confiance c'est la
force que nous allons redonner à la
france
voilà pour cette lecture du discours de
politique générale par laurent fabius au
sénat pendant ce temps là manuel valls
le premier ministre était lui à
l'assemblée nationale pour défendre la
feuille de route de son gouvernement
balle ce 2 face aux députés vous avez pu
l'entendre dans le gouvernement a tenté
de donner des gages à la gauche de la
gauche avec notamment une augmentation
du minimum vieillesse et cette prime de
40 euros qui sera donc accordé pour les
retraites les plus basses pour le
premier ministre c'est clair la france
n'est pas en période d'austérité puisque
de nouvelles dépenses sont engagés le
premier ministre qui a également cherché
à montrer une certaine fermeté vis-à-vis
de l'allemagne encore une fois un gage à
la gauche de la gauche alors est-ce que
cela va suffire rien n'est moins sûr
puisque 32 députés socialistes frondeurs
se sont tout de même abstenus ce qui
laisse augurer des discussions assez
houleuse pour les textes importants de
cette fin d'année notamment et bien le
budget 2014 et le budget de la sécurité
sociale
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les séances notre site sur
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée sur
les chaînes parlementaires